they will take on the reds right-handed
rookie vladimir gutierrez demaio mai has
vladimir gutierrez been good
swing at the miss
gutierrez gets his first k
a scoreless top half of the first
pitch arsenal
for kyle sinker change up four-seam
fastball and curveball
on the ground out to short
romine will take it himself throws to
first
and that is that
6-3 the double play
and kyle hendricks pitching around the
walk one out walk for ortega and the
cubs
here in the third it'll bring up frank
schwendelman
that's on the ground that's a fair ball
down the line schwendel
looks like he's got another extra base
head ortega speeding around third on his
way to the plate and he's in the score
frank schwendell
sixth straight game with an extra base
hit and here in the third it knocks in a
run cubs lead one nothing definitely bad
here in the fourth inning they have a
one to nothing lead
[Music]
well hit deep right center field
leap at the wall show gowakiyama
defense
when shogo is in the outfield the plays
that this man is making out there
that's all about speed
and no fear whatsoever
that's a great play
[Applause]
comebacker look out india backhand has
time makes the throw
oh and by the way that young man right
there he's made some pretty good
defensive plays too
swing in the mid strike three
a seven pitch inning thanks in part to
shogo akiyama
hendrix has retired nine in a row he has
faced one over the minimum
[Applause]
weak ground ball
booty
nice shovel leaping throw little eight
[Applause]
center field ortega
won't get there first base end of the
ball game
blister
prophet larkin
outside corner got him looking great
pitch
and a little roller right side body has
it
and unloads and hendricks
pitches out of that jab
don't see a lot of one-nothing games at
the great american ball park but we've
got one tonight
he and hamp will be first up
and that ball's drilled right field that
one back on its way and gone
half with a rocket to right
he got out front that time and blasted
it over the wall
and it's two nothing
and for ian hat number 13.
comes back with the change up and he
hangs it
and
absolutely murders that baseball
crushes it to right field no doubter
castianos turned around and said i'm
gonna stop running that's out of here
back here in cincinnati we go bottom six
and it's two nothing
this one's skied in the year left field
half coming on
and near the line
india retired he's old for 3-1 down
lotto aggressive first pitch swinging
and pops it in the air to half
and two quick outs
nick castellanos to the plate
castellanos high fly deep right center
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well just a matter of time hendricks has
been really good
but this
is the mistake
cubs in cincinnati a 2-1 lead over the
reds here in the bottom half of the
seventh inning matt duffy pinch hitting
for kyle hendricks he swings and lines
one into left field for a base hit it'll
roll all the way to the wall
duffy around first he cruises into
second base with a stand-up double and
the cubs in business here in the first
half of the seventh inning the
left-handed justin wilson is in for the
reds
popped him up
castellanos
[Applause]
smoke to third caught on the hop by
mustaches makes the throw what a pick
oh flash the leather if you will moose
hot shot
not on my watch
and in this booth for rookie of the year
jonathan india hitless tonight
bats bases loaded
deals
right there got him
rowan wick freezes india and there's two
away the lefty adam morgan takes over
first one of otto
back up the middle
romine has it throw to first got him
and morgan pumps his fists they're able
to get the big bopper for the reds
nobody out
cubs trying to add some insurance
chase one in the dirt nice job by
stevenson the corraler first k processor
[Applause]
farmer
india
make it three
comes
enjoying a two-one lead
swing and a miss struck him out and
hoyer gets farmer good job by cody
and one away
the o2
belts to the right side romaine takes it
in fires to first and the cubs are an
out away
[Applause]
field one
in the air out towards left center or
messiah is there and that's the ball
game cubs win
cody hoyer closes it out good job by the
bullpen here tonight
you